لحظات قليله وتصل سفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل الى مرسى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
هنا في جده بعد رحله استغرقت عشر ساعات
ذهابا وعشره الساعات عوده من ميناء بورت
السودان على متن هذه السفينه اثنين وخمسين
شخص من بين الدبلوماسيين وعائلات واطفال
وكبار سن والاشخاص من ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه تم اجلاؤهم من السودان وتحديدا من
ميناء بورت السودان وصلت الان كما تشاهدون
امامكم على الكاميرا لقطات حصريه ومباشره
دقائق معدوده وترسوا هذه السفينه على على
رصيف قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده نتحدث
على 52 الشخص من 12 جنسيه منهم دبلوماسيين
نتحدث على جنسيات نتحدث على من جنوب
افريقيا ومن كندا ومن امريكا وكذلك عرب
وجنسيات مختلفه ونتحدث ان هذه العمليه هي
استمرارا لعمليات الاجلاء التي تعمل عليها
القوات البحريه السعوديه منذ ايام وتحديدا
من قاعده الملك فيصل الى ميناء بورت سودان
والعوده بالرعايه بشكل مستمر خلال الساعات
الماضيه استقبلت قاعده الملك فيصل عدد من
السفن البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وعلى
متنها كذلك رعايه نتحدث على المنفذ الجوي
وهو قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه ايضا
استقبلت الطائرات ايضا نتحدث على ميناء
جده الاسلامي لا زال يستمر باستقبال السفر
التجاريه اعداد كبيره يتم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريني نتحدث عن اعداد تصل او تتجاوز
الالفين وسبعمائه شخص تم اجلائهم من اكثر
من 58 جنسيه هذه الرحله كانت واسطه تامين
وحمايه من قوات البحريه السعوديه يعني
كانت رافقناها خلال الرحله
ذهابا وايابا كنالك عمليات اجلاء كانت
دقيقه جدا وباحترافيه عاليه في حال وصولنا
الى ميناء بورسودان لم نتبقى سوى ساعه
واحده حتى تم جلب كافه الرعايه عبر زوارق
السريعه خاصه بالبح السعوديه وتم ادخالهم
الى هذه السفينه العسكريه الضخمه التي
يعني بها عدد كبير من الاعتاد العسكري
وطائرته هليكوبتر للبحث والانقاذ وهي
مجهزه ومزوده بكافه التفاصيل الخاصه
بالرعايه تتحدثنا فيما يتعلق انه تم توفير
غرف نوم وثكنات لاستراحه الرعايه وكذلك
توفير التموين الغذائي والمشروبات وما
شابه ذلك نهيك عن وجود عياده طبيه تعاملت
مع عدد من الحالات الطبيه من قبل الرعايه
للتاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم وكذلك التعامل
مع الحالات او الامراض المزمنه التي مصاب
بها عدد من الرعايه كل هذه الخدمات من
التموين والخدمات اللوجستيه والنفسيه
والطبيه تم تقديمها على متن السفينه جلاله
الملك الجبيل في رحله استغرقت 10 ساعات
ذهابا وعشره ساعات ايابا كما نشاهد الان
وصلنا الى رصيف قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده خلال دقائق معدوده وسوف تبدا عمليات
الانزال الى قاعده ومن ثم سوف يتم
اجراءات السفر الخاصه ب 52 شخص باختلاف
جنسيتهم ومن ثم سوف يتم نقله الى مقرات
السكن للاستراحه وانهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر حتى يستطيعوا الذهاب الى بلدانهم في
اقرب وقت ممكن نعم طيب السلطان على مدار
الايام الماضيه تحدثت عن اجلاء 2700 شخص
او اكثر من 2700 شخص هل كل هؤلاء يعني
الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم على متن سفن
سعوديه من ميناء بورت سودان الى جده هل
يتم تسكينهم في جده قبل مغادرتهم الى
بلادهم ام هناك مدن اخرى في السعوديه
تستقبل هؤلاء
بالفعل عدد كبير من السفن البحريه
السعوديه يتجاوز الثمانيه السفن حتى هذه
اللحظه قامت باجلاء عدد كبير يتجاوز 2,700
شخص باختلاف جنسيتهم من ميناء بورت سودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده او
واسطه او عبر سفن بحريه مجهزه بكامل
الاعتاد العسكري لتامين وحمايه هؤلاء
الرعايه حتى وصولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه عند وصوله من القاعده هنا يتم
استقبالهم من قبل سفرائهم وممثلين
دبلوماسيين لهؤلاء الرعايه في ظل تنسيق
كبير موجات الخارجيه السعوديه وعدم الجهات
الحكوميه حتى يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات
السفر او اجراءات الدخول الخاصه بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومن ثم يتم الكشف عليهم
طبيا حتى يتم التاكد من سلامتهم وبعد ذلك
يتم انهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم في
ظرف ساعه واحده فقط وبعد ذلك يتم انتقالهم
الى مقرات السكن وهي عباره عن اربعه فنادق
رئيسيه خصصتها الحكومه السعوديه حتى
يستطيعون هؤلاء الرعايه الاستراحه بها ومن
ثم بعد ذلك يتم انهاء اجراءات السفر
الخاصه بهم من قبل حكوماتهم ومن قبل
الحكومه السعوديه والسفر عبر مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده كما نشاهد عدد
كبير من القوات الامنيه يتواجدون هنا
لاستقبال هؤلاء الرعايه والتاكد من سلامه
نزوله من هذه السفينه وحتى يتم
بعد ذلك اجراءات السفر ووصول الى حافلات
تم تخصيصها من قبل الحكومه السعوديه وبعد
ذلك يتم نقلهم الى مقرات السابق السكن
ايضا نؤكد انه عمليات الاجلال لا تزال
مستمره كما اعلن كما اعلنت السفاره
السعوديه في الخرطوم انها تستقبل اعداد
كبيره من طلبات الاجلاء الى السعوديه
وتحديدا الى مدينه جده نتحدث عن عداد
كبيره تستقبلها بشكل او طلبات تستقبلها
بشكل دائم ومستمر يتم دراسته والموافقه
على عدد كبير منها الملحوظ خلال الايام
الماضيه منذ بدا الاجلاب هو التنوع في
الجنسيات والازدياد بشكل كبير في الطلبات
منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء السعوديه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه خلال يوم قال له
يومين الماضيه ووصلت السفينه وحيده تجاريه
الى قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه تسمى بامانه
على متنها 1667 شخص من اكثر من اربعين
الجنسيه نؤكد ان الحكومه السعوديه تتعامل
مع كل الرعايه الاجانب والسعوديين على
مستوى واحد من خلال تقديم الخدمات
اللوجستيه الطبيه
والاعاشيه الخاصه بهم ومن ثم انهاء كافه
الاجراءات السفر الخاصه به من قبل قطاعات
الحكوميه الاخرى
من ردود الفعل لتسهيل وهذا تبعناه جميعا
سلطان الربود الفعل الدوليه من الشق صحيح
تفضل
نعم اثناء رحلتنا الى منبورت من ميناء
بورت سودان واجلاء الرعايه وصولا الى الان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده التقيت
بعدد كبير من الرعايه الذين تقدموا
امتنانهم وشكرهم للحكومه السعوديه وللقوات
البحريه السعوديه على رحابه الاستقبال
وكيفيه الاستقبال وتقديم كافه المستلزمات
الخاصه بهم من خلال تجهيز غرف النوم وكذلك
فتح العياده طول طوال الساعات طوال ساعات
السفر ايضا يتحدث على وجود الاعاشه طوال
ساعات السفر من خلال المشروبات والفواكه
والتموين بمختلف اشكاله ايضا وجود مختصين
نفسيين للتعامل مع الحالات التي هي متاثره
جراء الاشتباكات المسلحه في الخرطوم او
حتى الولايات التابعه للخرطوم ايضا
التقينا بقصص كثيره وعديده رولنا مشاعرهم
وكيف كانهم يعيشون حالات صعبه وماساويه في
الخرطوم جراء الاشتباكات المسلحه بين
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
رووا لنا انه بعد وص ميناء بورت سودان
ومشاهده السفن البحريه السعوديه اختلفت
المشاعر وشاعره بالاطمئنان بشكل كبير
وايضا عند اقترابنا من قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ومشاهدتها بلعين ايضا يعني شعروا
وقالوا لنا وصرحوا لنا هنالك شعور بوصولنا
الى بر الامان بعد معاناه كبيره وفوضى
عارمه عاشوا تفاصيلها في السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه منذ بدء الاشتباكات
المسلحه هناك يعني في الجهه المقابله من
السفينه هنالك الرعايه تواجدون الالتقاط
الصور التذكاريه وتوثيق هذه اللحظات
السعيده بطبيعه الحال بعد معاناه كبيره
عاشوها هنالك في الخرطوم لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات